prüfung tag und goethe stadt deutsch 1
das komplette vokabular mit dialogen
lektion 4
47 wörter
los geht's
der laden die läden
legen
das buch die bücher
im buchladen können sie bücher kaufen
legen sie die bücher auf den tisch
schnell sind oft sehr teuer
hier sind oft sehr teuer
welcher
welche
welches
bestellen
abholen
nächste ja
nächste
nächstes
die woche
die wochen
geöffnet
welches buch möchte si
welches buch möchten sie
heidi von johanna spyri
dieses buch haben wir nicht
sollen wir es für sie bestellen
ja wann kann ich es bei ihnen abholen
wann kann ich es bei ihnen abholen
nächste woche
aber bei si
der laden ist samstags nur bis 16 uhr
geöffnet
aber
si
der laden ist samstags nur bis 16 uhr
geöffnet
der reiseführer
vielleicht
eine million
millionen
eine milliarde
milliarden
kaufe mir einen reiseführer für berlin
auch wenn wir einen reiseführer für
berlin
braucht
vielleicht auch ein wörterbuch englisch
deutsch
brauchen sie vielleicht auch ein
wörterbuch englisch deutsch
in diesem wörterbuch finden sie mehr als
20.000 wörter
[Musik]
in diesem wörterbuch finden sie mehr als
20.000 wörter
der kiosk
der bleistift die bleistifte
jeder
jede
jedes die lebensmittel
bekommen sie getränke zigaretten und
zeitungen
am kiosk bekommen sie getränke
zigaretten und zeitungen
bleistifte können sie auch an jedem
kiosk kaufen
mittel bekommen sie im supermarkt
lebensmittel bekommen sie im supermarkt
die zeitung die zeitungen
das getränk
die getränke
die flasche
die flaschen
ich lese gern
ich lese gern diese zeitung
mein lieblingsgetränk ist bier
eine flasche bier bitte
die zigarette
die zigaretten
über
rauchen
wie teuer sind die zigaretten
teuer sind die zigaretten
sind sie über 18
ich rauche nicht ich
nur
ein gramm
und
ein kilo
kilogramm
der apfel die äpfel
ein von tetzel bitte
ein fund äpfel bitte
wie viel
die banane die bananen
die birne die birnen
wie viele bananen si
wie viele bananen wollen sie
3 bitte
ein kilo birnen bitte
das obst
das gemüse
die tomate
die tomaten
diese
dieses
im sommer ist das obst billig
[Musik]
gemüse brauchen wir auch noch
die tomaten sind sehr gut
wir nehmen lieber diesen körpers
die anzeige
die anzeigen
die reise
fliegen
liebe
die bahn
wir haben ihre anzeige in der zeitung
gesehen
wir möchten eine reise nach deutschland
buchen
wir fliegen nicht gern
deshalb fahren wir lieber mit der bahn
der anschluss
bleiben
von saarbrücken nach trier
ca
sich freuen
in mannheim haben sie anschluss nach
saarbrücken
in saarbrücken bleiben sie drei tage und
dann fahren sie nach trier
von saarbrücken nach trier sind es circa
100 kilometer
[Musik]
die fahrkarte bekommen sie am bahnhof
ich freue mich auf den urlaub
weiter geht's im nächsten video